and i was like i think i'm pregnant bro
and he was like gosh so culture like
this baby in there
it's baby baby cardi b
opened up about expecting baby number
two revealing how offset and culture
reacted to the big news
there's some big big things on the way
big bangs
on tuesday the rapper made a surprise
appearance on barty gang radio
where she took fans inside her pregnancy
journey this year
hey guys how you guys doing cardi said
signs
first popped up in the weeks leading up
to the grammy awards where she and megan
the stallion did their much talked about
performance of wap
it was like two weeks before grammys i
was still in rehearsal
you know i get a lot of headache but
like i just started like my mouth
started to get real
watery
and i started getting real carsick and
everything
when it came time to tell hubby offset
cardi said they couldn't help but laugh
at the surprise pregnancy
when you told offset and
culture that you were pregnant what was
their initial reaction
and i was like i think i'm pregnant bro
and he was like gosh
and then we got a pregnancy test
and i was i came out of the bathroom i'm
like yup it's positive
and we just started like laughing like
oh lord
because we have so much to do when cardi
let culture know she was going to be a
big sister
she got this adorable response so
culture like this baby in there
it's baby it's baby like she knows
there's a baby so she like
don't jump on me like she used to
cardi and offset recently through
culture a fairy tale themed birthday
party
wow
yep that's the birthday girl arriving to
the party in a literal carriage ride
happy birthday happy birthday
birthday and cardi said because they
went all out for the bash
she sidestepped any plans for a baby
shower
that's why i did like coaches birthday
really really big
because i just get really overwhelmed
when i do these big birthdays
and i just feel like the baby shower
with culture birthdays just too close
just to see the same people over again
according to cardi her pregnancy with
culture wasn't exactly stress-free
and the experience led to her taking a
break from social media this year
i took a break not only because oh my
gosh i'm pregnant so i gotta have my
pregnancy
like it's like i took that little
internet break because i had to get my
mind together
i feel like people put me through a lot
of
during coaches pregnancy
a lot of lies were made about me
absolutely
a lot of narratives i never really
wanted to tell the world that i was
pregnant but i knew i had to
in the end cardi said being pregnant the
second time around
has provided some peace amid her busy
career it's like i don't know like when
i get deals and when i go number one and
my song is doing good i'm happy but yet
i'm still overwhelmed because i'm
thinking about
the next record or what can i do next
but this pregnancy has brought me like a
little piece
and it's just something that is like so
dear it's just a new chapter